mais on aurait dû le mettre à ce mythe
l'aspect va revenir ça à slim ou thala
vivement la dèche magnifique magnifique
toi tu as des cheveux magnifiques ni
passé ni l'école ni derrière rien n'y a
rien qui bouge
je vais dire quelque chose si tu perds
pas tes cheveux à 40 ans et qui
vieillissent et que tu dis perdra jamais
tu peux toucher turban noir sequanux que
tu fais déjà du ricin tombé sur le corps
aussi
mignot tuiles sur le corps toi il ne
joue pas je m'aligne comment tu sais toi
non pas du tout je mets 2002 de morue de
l'huile de jojoba bulle de voilure de
jojo mimoun de l'huile de taux oui on y
va bonsoir commenté l'évangile à bahreïn
bénabar ça va ça va tu joues à la
primaube août mais jai vue pas celui là
fait pas que ce soit l'aspect vous
écoutez battue je me suis dit c'est
dingue
si voix la primaube route également le
week end analyses et des femmes qui se
passe ici se passe j'ai parlé avec
madame bahamas et perso c'est sûrement
pas du tout parlé sans succès
alors vous le dites mais si sa résidence
y aura plus de guerre alors c'est pas
vulgaire du tout c'est quoi c'est pas
vulgaire je bête jardinant les ennuis
c'est géraldine qui misait voilà la vie
avance je ne demande pas d'amour je
demande une expérience et je lui dis je
suis libre faisait rien ce soir je suis
foule alors bon soir alors vous savez je
suis très ému ce soir parce qu'on fait
nos trois mois ensemble
la pas que ça qu'on fait
vous savez ce qu'on fait ce soir je
serai là et la millième d'isabelle
morini-bosc voilà sa 1000e
on est content pas vous quand vous serez
avoir 1000e a bataillé plus que ça vous
avez vous plus que minime oui un frère
tu le double salaire pour ça au moins
alors messieurs commencé avec un goujat
on est autant atteignent c'est un ami
j'ai commencé avec un de vos 2 150
animateurs préférés cyril david ginola
qui obtient le laury's l'animateur qui a
son propre langage
pour monsieur jean joute est merci à
vous d'avoir passé la soirée avec nous
ont cassé mais là tout de suite fait
beaucoup de pub pour les shampoings mais
quand il anime on dirait qu'il a fait de
la pub pour du dentifrice retour tout de
suite sur les duos les plus marquants
mais aussi les plus improbables des
années 80 regardez
des confidences envie de toi
souvenez-vous ce qui lui plaît t'as le
look coco en oublier son sourire colgate
total
on est rassuré il a quatre à l'arrière
ça n'a pas du tout marché produit c'est
la faute à meyer ses huit étaient en
prime time devant voilà donc bravo à la
chaîne qui a fini d'avoir des années ses
envies dab et bravo à jason statham je
bénis serait rouge comme c'est vrai
article saaq
sauf que vous notez quand même je suis
pas méchant quand il fait un carton
c'est lui le carton ah oui ça n'a pas
marché c'est pas de sa faute
avez-vous il ya un moment bah oui quand
l'animateur responsable je protège
toujours les animateurs regard des vrais
ou l'aï regardé benhaim sur les protéger
samuel barril le rappel trois fois à ben
oui quoi voulez-vous être au fait des
signes à ce que parce qu'il faut que
vous sachiez vous de mérite à l'heure
c'est qu'un gars lui de 8 à la fédé
ouais on dirait que tu as volé mon père
était sans doute des combinaisons à ce
mal à m'imaginer ilana m'imaginer lui
s'appelle comment ton ami imaginaire
mon ami m'a dit non c'est pas vrai a
réussi sa lame l'imaginaire non mais tu
paies dessine il se parle à lui-même
non je veux je veux je vais la main mais
pourquoi on en est et où
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le cas ils se croient en classe par
excusez moi la géographie merci on
continue c'est cédric comme ils
s'appellent mais cédric si tous alors
dans cette émission sur les années 80
sur m6 j'ai eu la surprise de vous voir
cyril hanouna
je savais que vous étiez fan de mon ami
josé d'hélène et les garçons away mais
savez pas qui c'est y aller jusqu'à
apprendre le synthé comme lui c'est
incroyable vous faites donc des
remplacements dans des groupes de
musique bénabar ça peut vous intéresser
c'est le lorie d'animateurs qui a fait
partie du groupe partenaire particulier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est de ces montages une seule dans ce
que vous avez fait c'est ça le génie et
c'est que vous avez femmes de travailler
ensemble en vue d'un merci alors est ce
que quelqu'un tient à garder une fois
dans sa vie la chaîne amc historique est
génial j'adore mais qui jamais regardé
son marché avec la chaîne car on passe
et numéros 23 que personne ne regarde et
non plus assez c'est sans arrêter de
mentir et donc forcément pour booster
son audience et patron de rmc on fait
appel à jean jacques bourdin qui
présente une émission qui s'appelle rien
est impossible on s'appelle rennes est
impossible mais vu les audiences est
possible ne pas regarder l'émission
c'est une émission de débat qui on a
rappelé une odeur des durs et des mous
qualitatif
vous allez voir c'est pas si qualitatif
que sa jambe internet ici le laurier du
programme que tu regardes que si ta box
est bloqué sur la chaîne the curve ou
quoi ah non vous allez voir je
retrouverai se lève à 4 heures du matin
donc à 21h le prendre dans ten il dort
les yeux ouverts bonsoir à toutes et à
tous
en regardant l'émission je me suis dit
que les couleurs du plateau la régie un
peu en retard écoutons le regardons le
bien les sondages les intervenants dans
le public et même le logo ça me rappelle
quelque chose c'est pas
si le début de l'émission en revanche
n'avait rien à voir avec une mise en
scène incroyable
l'église catholique doit-elle autoriser
le mariage des prêtres alors plus
dépressifs comme intro ça aurait pu être
ça aussi un le mariage des prêtres au
pied on a vu hier cyril aurait fallu
bourdin comment cette émission comme ça
le mariage des prêtres
c
god of thunder
nous vous avez milité pour que la
pétanque de l'anneau sport olympique
mais je pratique un sport depuis
quelques temps que j'ai envie de voir
prendre de l'ampleur je vous préviens il
faut avoir une oreille très musclé
vraiment c'est très important oui une ré
très musclé ses lauriers du sport qu'il
faut absolument jeux olympiques génial
mais j'adore pour toi ça après ça j'ai
envie de le faire ce week-end et gustov
possible c'est la vraie la grèce la blu
ray bon tu sais pas une crise mais avec
un frisbee quand même non je supprime
pas notre ennemi c'est alors si vous
avez des vieux cd chez vous devenez que
je ne voulais plus maintenant faut pas
que c'est dans ce décor un peu gênant
c'est un peu gênant mais bon voilà tu
n'auras pas alors vous êtes de bonne
humeur mais pour finir je voudrais
aborder un sujet qui m'a rendu chaque
point qui va vous rendre à fond mais
conçu sûr j'aimerais ouvrir sur une
mascarade qui a eu lieu hier soir sur ce
plateau une mascarade pire encore une
tartufferie ou là on sait que vous aimez
mettre en valeur vos chroniqueurs ça oui
c'est comme par exemple hier soir la
séquence finale qu'on revoie derrière
moi d'ailleurs tu parlais tout à l'heure
par l'état lorsque je vais revoir la
tête de benayoun teurs vous allez voir
ses meilleures têtes du monde voit les
magnifiques ils ont juste avant le drame
et un chroniqueur qui a voulu faire
pleurer dans les chaumières en disant
qu'il ne fallait pas salir le blouson
qu'il a été très cher c'est bien sûr
mètres de l'en but [ __ ] mais non mais
non c'est rien du tout tenait à la
maison qui vaut cher
pas du tout aller
allez tous les wc c'est à quel point il
a peur de salir un blouson qu'il a dû
payer très cher moi je pourrais
comprendre
bah oui sauf que je vais vous dévoiler
toute la vérité sur ce blouson repartons
le 14 novembre dernier manque de bol
pour mathieu avant l'émission un
téléphone filmer ce jour là dans la loge
de cyril hanouna dans matthieu fouilles
dans le dressing la saison il à
l'antenne regarder dans un bon jour
qu'il faut effectivement chez m il n'a
pas payé puisqu'il a payé ainsi
réplication l'humour mais non ça vaut
cher mais tu n'as pas payer donc tu peux
pas mais par as
[Applaudissements]
à